[音楽]
あああああああああっ ua の復興で回レ回レ回レ回だろうでかいだー
理解だろでかいです yy ダメだろそのもある大また
侵略者が俺の家に来たんだなそうだ私はお前の家を侵略するためにでかくなってきたん
だ
それ救う一枚しか来てないですか f 組っ
1枚そうだよ色気を出そうとして服1枚しか着て来なかったんだよ
いやでも確かにかわいいんですけど祝いけどなんか違うんですよ
えっが何の目的で俺んちに来た最近あんまりいいことがないからなんかここに来れば
いいことがあるんじゃないかと思ってきたんだけどそのポビーでどうやって入ってきた
んですか探して店
その隙間からこう身体をねじ込んで入ってきたなぁある方どうぞ
すごいだろうすごいの特に胸の感じがすごいな謎4へ本当に扱いまして
いやちょっと触ってみていいですかいやいいよいいよ
ちょっと様がせていろいろぞ
嫌なコトルってなんですか何かあったんすかえっなんか最近
けせらんぱさらというものを見つけてけせらんぱふぇらー
ケセランパサランなんですよ伊勢乱パセなんていう高
ちょっと若干想像上の一斉うチックな生き物みたいのがいるんだけど
なるほどなるほど
こいつを品川駅で発見して品は生き
長和駅この見た目で見ながら駅すごいへ全然置いてない全然いける感じです受ける
溶け込んでる感じでそれで見つけたんだけど
植物なのか動物なのかはっきりしないみたいに言われてる凄くこうちょっとこう夢が
あるデイヴつ小さいきんたんも沿いの道
歩いていた時に何かこうケセラセラこういうものがまた浮いてて
したらあそこで好き坂最中って思ったんだけど火を見てみるとその他の植物から削ら
ポスターが大量発生しててこれでも成績皿小皿のことなのかなみたいな俺があるんです
彼らが発生してそれがなんかちょっと桑田氏が来るんじゃって伝説の位置も多くが
ちょっというかなと思ってなんかこう
残念な気持ちになりました
ご覧に出てましたねてました申し訳ないけどそれっ
ちゃーちょっと本当に帰ってほしいんだちょっと帰りたくなるほどの友達とか様から
本当にドン引きされるやつなんですよ
そう広くないよそこまでではないがいやなんかもうそんな存在自体がも何か一種の
カテゴリーに属しちゃうよ
そんなひどくはなぁ帰ってくださいありがとう絶対に買いたくないで絶対に買いたく
ないで
絶対に私は変わらないです社長がむしろ帰れと a は遊歩私は絶対に帰るきましてっ
[音楽]
バッハ